Why Vampires Can't Exist... and 9 Other Amazing
Facts
1.
How do we know vampires don’t exist?
If each vampire ate just 1 meal a day, starting
with just 1 vampire and each victim then turning
into a vampire, it would take about 1 month
for the entire human population to become
vampires.
(QF 466)
2.
Pearls will dissolve if placed in vinegar
as they are mostly made up of calcium carbonate,
easily dissolved by acetic acid, which is
most of what vinegar is.
(QF 510)
3.
The 7 Wonders of the Ancient World were: the
Great Pyramid of Giza (2584-2561 BC), the
Hanging Gardens of Babylon (600 BC), the Temple
of Artemis at Ephesus (550 BC), the Statue
of Zeus at Olympia (435 BC), Mausoleum at
Halicarnassus (351 BC), the Colossus of Rhodes
(292-280 BC), and the Lighthouse of Alexandria
(280 BC).
It should be noted though that many historians
doubt that the Hanging Gardens ever actually
existed.
(QF 519)
4.
If you live in the U.S., you are nearly four
times as likely to be killed by a vending
machine as a shark, with an average annual
death rate of 2.18 for vending machines and
0.6 deaths from shark attacks.
(QF 540)
5.
You are about 40% more likely to survive a
commercial plane crash if you sit in the back
row of the plane compared to the front row,
according to a study done by Popular Mechanics
covering every accident aboard commercial
planes from 1971 to 2007.
(QF 542)
6.
“Nazi” isn’t just the name of a one-time
prominent political party, but also the Swahili
word for “coconut”.
(QF 551)
7.
Ever wonder what the Q in Q-tips stands for?
Wonder no more- it stands for “Quality”.
Before they were given that name, they were
called “Baby Gays”, invented and named
in the 1920s by Leo Gerstenzang.
(QF 566)
8.
The wife of famed poet Henry Wadsworth Longfellow
tragically died when she accidentally dropped
a burning match onto her hoop skirt, which
burst into flames and ultimately killing her.
(QF 578)
9.
Despite being twice as abundant as iron in
the earth’s crust, in much of the 19th century,
aluminum cost more than gold due to the difficulty
in isolating it from other substances.
For reference, in the 1850s, one ingot of
aluminum went for $550 (about $15,000 today).
By 1900, thanks to technological advancements,
the same ingot was selling for just 25 cents
($7 today).
(QF 584)
10.
In the time it takes you to listen to this,
hundreds of billions of neutrinos have passed
through your body.
Specifically, close to 65 billion neutrinos
from the Sun pass through every square centimeter
of you that is currently perpendicular to
the Sun every single second that passes.
(QF 587)